I was thinking about this man. I was thinking about,
I was in a conversation with a bunch of people who was I talking about this with
about like Dan Bilzerian, that guy that does all the, um,
flying around with the chicks.
Like I was thinking about that.
And I was thinking about how that's quote unquote, every guy's fantasy, right.
To just have, you know, 10 chicks around or the, you know,
the Hugh Hefner thing. Right?
Like where you just got 10 chicks and you just around there around,
and you're just always around them and all that. And I was thinking about like,
if they had that choice, like, like, like here's the thing, dude,
having sex with a bunch of different women. Sure.
That's I understand that want that's cool and that's can be hot and it's great.
Whatever,
but what's up with this guy though.
What's up with,
and the guy seems happy and and no knock on the dude,
the guy's doing what he wants to do, but you,
this guy is not doing that. He's like, you gotta, Oh,
you gotta be on a plane with them for six hours.
Like,
that's the thing that I don't get like this guy's always chilling with them
and I'm not saying it's not fun to be around 10 chicks.
I'm saying it's not fun to be around 10 thoughts.
It's not it's it's, it's not.
And maybe there's something wrong with me. Okay. Like,
but like if Dan and he would never,
because I'm boring as. But if he asked me to be like, yo,
we're going to New York, get on the private jet.
These 12 thoughts are going to come with us. I would be like, Oh bro, I can't,
I can't go dude. And then he would be like,
but look at the girls. And I would be like, yeah,
but they're going to talk and stuff. What are I'd say? Yeah.
But what are we going to talk about?
What are we going to say?
I get one, I get having sex with all of the girls is fun,
but then they're all at your house.
And they're like, where did I put my in? You're like, Oh,
I don't know. And the girl's like, you're always losing.
And then the other one's like, well, um, hello.
People just think I should be a comedian because like I'm always losing stuff
and I'm movie just commenting on it. And then another girl was like,
you should be.
And they just have shirt on and I gotta be like, yeah,
you should be a comedian. Or what, what or what, what do I say to that?
If I'm in that situation, I go like this. Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, no,
I just don't. I don't get it. I don't get that life. I wish. And I, like I said,
no, knock on the dude. And the chicks are, they're having fun. He's having fun.
That's great. You know, it's like me. I don't want to go to a football game.
You know? I'm not, I'm not,
I'm never going to look at another guy running with a ball and actually be like,
you. Like I whooped for what?
He went to the place. He went to the end.
[inaudible] see. He doesn't even know who I am. I don't give a.
I get busted in common, but hanging.
I get bustin in and common,
but hanging.
I get busted in common,
but on a plane to New York.
Okay.
I just don't. I don't know. I don't get it. Maybe I like, I think a lot of guys,
I th I, I think a lot of guys would not choose that. Right?
W w I want to know what kind of guy would go on that trip.
The girls are hot, dude. They're all real hot. Not, you know,
I'm not going to be one of those guys. Here's what's annoying. The guy was like,
those girls aren't even hot, dude. Shut up, dude. Shut the up.
Those girls are all hot. Hot girls are hot girls. Yeah. Dude,
the guy who's like, you know, I don't care if the boobs aren't big.
If they're fake. Nah, dude, shut up.
No knock on small bulbs. That small balls can be great.
But do it just because they're fake doesn't mean they're bad. Yeah.
Girls who got the too much, too much of the. Nah,
not for me. You're in your cubicle. Just fat.
You know, just
Hot girls are hot girls. Okay. My point is being on a plane with them,
12 of them when they're just doing Instagram stories,
jumping out. I'm good. This is how I'm having a conversation.
Okay. Cool.
Birds.
Wow. What are you doing here? Oh dude. Thoughts,
Mark.
Mark. What are you doing here? Why are you?
Why are you jumping out of the plane? Oh.
Girl. Up there said she should be a comedian.
And all of her friends think that she should be a comedian.
You did the right thing.
She said, she's the silliest girl in the.
World. She's not,
what are you doing down here?
The girl up there said that one time she met Tiger's brother.
Yeah. You did the right thing.